WATERS.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK AND THIS
IS "THE FIVE."
>> MAY THE BEST CORVETTE WIN.
ON YOUR MARK, GET SET, GO!
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN THINKS
DEMOCRATS ARE CRUISING TO
VICTORY IN 12 DAYS.
HIS WHITE HOUSE IS NERVOUS THAT
THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF GAS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DRIVING MORE
THAN 100 MILES PER HOUR WHILE
BEHIND THE WHEEL OF A CLASSIC
CORVETTE ON JAY LENO'S CAR SHOW.
IT'S HIS LAST DITCH EFFORT AT
COURTING GOP VOTERS.
MR. BIDEN HOPES HIS GEAR HEAD
REPUTATION WILL APPEAL TO SOME
PARTS OF THE REPUBLICAN BASE.
IT'S TRUE.
BUT POLITCO REPORTS HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT FEELING
THE SAME NEED FOR SPEED.
ANXIETY IS GROWING THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL CAPTURE ONE
CHAMBER OF CONGRESS AND POSSIBLY
BOTH.
WITH THOSE FEARS, PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN WILL STAY ON THE
SIDELINES.
BIDEN DID MAKE TIME TO TRAVEL TO
DEM FRIENDLY SYRACUSE, NEW YORK.
HE HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
>> GREAT ECONOMIC REPORT TODAY.
THE GDP REPORT.
THINGS ARE LOOKING GOOD.
>> Dana: THINGS ARE LOOKING
GOOD, GREG, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE BEHIND THE WHEEL OF A
CLASSIC CORVETTE.
>> Greg: I GET THEIR ANXIETY
OVER THE MID-TERMS.
IT'S LOGICAL.
THEY'RE IN A MESS.
THEY DESERVE NO SYMPATHY FOR
THIS.
THEY HAVE NO ANXIETY ABOUT THE
REASONS WHY THEY GOT THERE.
THEY HAVE NO ANXIETY ABOUT CRIME
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVE NO ANXIETY ABOUT
INFLATION AS THEY DENIED IT.
THEY HAD NO ANXIETY ABOUT
RECESSION OR THE BORDER.
THEY ONLY FEEL ANXIETY WHEN
THERE'S A PERSONAL THREAT TO
THEIR POWER.
NOW THEY'RE NERVOUS.
THE DEMS ARE LIKE A DRIVER WHOSE
CAR'S ENGINE HAS CRACKED BECAUSE
THEY NEVER CHANGED THE OIL, THEY
NEFF GOT A TUNE-UP.
WHEN THEY HEARD THE NOISES OF
THE ENGINE, THEY TURNED UP THE
RADIO.
NOW THEY'RE STUCK WITH THIS.
WHAT IS AMAZING ABOUT THAT STUNT
IS HOW OBVIOUS THE STUNT WAS.
THEY CALCULATED IT OUT.
HE'S NOT GOING TO HIT ANYBODY.
JAY PLAYS ALONG.
THE WHOLE STUNT IS TO CONVINCE
VOTERS THAT HE'S NOT SENILE.
THAT GRAMPS CAN STILL DRIVE THE
CAR.
I'M SURPRISED HE SAID IT'S NOT
RACIST.
AN EXTRA SIX INCHES OF LEG ROOM
THAT MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
CAN'T AFFORD.
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN AFFORD A
CLASSIC CORVETTE EITHER,
MR. AVIATOR SUNGLASSES.
>> Dana: HERALDO THOUGHT IT'S
FUNNY THAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
WOULD WRITE THAT THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE THINKS HIM GOING ON THE
JAY LENO SHOW WILL APPEAL TO
REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
SO WEIRD.
>> BEFORE I GET AN ANSWER TO
THAT, I MUST SAY I HAVE A
BIPARTISAN TIE ON AND GREG
GUTFELD HAS THE SAME TIME WHAT
ARE THE ODDS ON THAT.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD HAVE CALLED
ME THIS MORNING.
>> I'M A CERTIFIED GEAR HEAD
MYSELF.
A PROUD FORMER MEMBER OF THE
VALVE GRINDERS.
SO TO ME, WATCHING --
>> WHAT?
>> THE VALVE GRINDERS.
MY CAR CLUB FROM LONG ISLAND.
IT'S THE COOLEST THING THAT
BIDEN HAS EVER DONE.
>> Jesse: WAS JANEAN IN THAT
CLEANUP?
>> I WENT FASTER THAN HE DID.
>> WHO WOULD BE DRIVE SOMETHING
MURAL.
SO ANYWAY, IT'S NICE HE DID IT.
I WANT TO GET TO POLITICS.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS RACE IS AN
ABSOLUTE TOSS-UP RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE ONLY NUMBERS THAT
MATTER ARE THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
AND THE DOW.
IF THEY KEEP -- IF GAS KEEPS
GOING DOWN AND THE DOW KEEPS
GOING UP, I THINK YOU'LL HAVE AT
THE VERY WORST NOR THE DEMOCRATS
A DIVIDED GOVERNMENT.
THE DEMOCRATS FAVORS TO MAINTAIN
THE SENATE AND THE REPUBLICANS
IN THE HOUSE.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT FETTERMAN LATER
ON AND THAT PERFORMANCE AGAINST
DR. OZ.
BUT I THINK THAT IT'S ALL UP FOR
GRABS RIGHT NOW JUST LIKE THAT
RACE.
>> Dana: THE NEW YORK TIMES THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS PRESSING FOR
A BETTER ECONOMIC MESSAGE.
SURE, THINGS ARE BAD BUT THE
REPUBLICANS WILL MAKE IT WORSE.
TRUST US.
>> WE'RE THE ONES THAT TOLD YOU
THAT INFLATION WAS TRANSITORY.
WHEN JOE BIDEN COMES OUT TODAY
AND HE SAYS, WE HAD A GREAT
ECONOMIC REPORT.
YOU KNOW, HE MAKES IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE DOING A GREAT JOB EXCEPT
THE PRICE FOR FOOD IS THE SAME.
THE PRICE FOR GAS IS THE SAME.
AT THE END OF THE MONTH, THEY
KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO SPEND MORE
NEXT MONTH FOR HEATING OIL.
HIS ENTHUSIASM DOESN'T TRANSLATE
TO PEOPLE SAYING YEAH, I'M GOING
TO VOTE DEMOCRAT NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE IDEA THAT JOE BIDEN GETTING
IN TO A MUSCLE CAR IS GOING TO
CONVINCE ANY REPUBLICAN THAT
THEY -- THAT HE'S ONE OF THEIR
GUYS, NO, THIS GUY IS IN TO
ELECTRIC CARS.
HE'S DRIVING A CAR THAT
APPARENTLY IS WORTH $150,000
THAT VERY FEW PEOPLE HAVE.
ALSO IS A GUY WHO PUTTING ALL OF
THIS MONEY IN TO THE ECONOMY
THAT IS CREATING THE INFLATION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
STUPID.
GERALDO, I AGREE WITH YOU ON ONE
THING.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL WIN THE
HOUSE.
I BELIEVE THEY'LL WIN THE
SENATE.
THE BIG SHOCK IS THE DOWN BALLOT
RACES.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A
BENEFIT TO THE DOWN BALLOT RACES
BASED ON THE ENTHUSIASM OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WHAT ENTHUSIASM DOES THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY HAVE?
NONE.
JOE BIDEN, BY THE WAY, THIS
WEEKEND, HE'S NOT EVEN GOING OUT
POLITICKING.
HE'S GOING TO DELAWARE THIS
WEEKEND.
MY GOD.
WE'RE TEN DAYS AWAY FROM THE
MID-TERMS.
SO, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN TALK ALL
THEY WANT ABOUT GREAT ECONOMIC
REPORTS.
THE AMERICANS KNOW WHAT THE
TRUTH IS.
>> Dana: IT'S LIKE THE WHITE
HOUSE WOULD LOVE TO PUMP
MORPHINE IN TO THE VOTING PUBLIC
SO THEY CAN FEEL CALM.
>> Dana: THE AFFORD ABILITY
ISSUE ON HOUSING, THAT'S ANOTHER
THING THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO GET A GOOD
RENTAL.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO
BUY A HOME OR BUILD IT OR BUY
FURNITURE.
IN WHAT UNIVERSE DID THE
DEMOCRATS THINK THAT THEY HAD A
SHOT IN THIS ELECTION?
I'LL TELL YOU, THE TWITTER
VERSE.
BECAUSE YOU GO ON THE
TWITTERVERSE AND BEING A
DEMOCRAT, YOU GO ON TWITTER,
IT'S LIKE TALKING TO YOUR MOM.
SHE SHOWS YOU UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO OR SAY,
TWITTER WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC FEELS.
THEY'LL KICK YOUR ASS OUT OF
THERE IF YOU DON'T PERFORM.
I UNDERSTAND THE ANXIETY FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THE WAY THEY'RE SCARED IS SO BIG
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT GET THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE BACK FOR
SEVERAL CYCLES.
AND THAT MEANS NO LEGISLATIVE
WINS THAT MEANS NO SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE CONFIRMATIONS.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT A FEW DARK
YEARS.
TELL ME IF YOU UNDERSTAND THE
STRATEGY, GERALDO.
LAST WEEK JOE BIDEN INVITED A
TRANSSEXUAL AND TALKED ABOUT
DOING GENDER REASSIGNMENT
SURGERIES ON CHILDREN.
THE VERY NEXT WEEK HE COMES OUT
AND GOES ON JAY LENO'S SHOW AND
TRIES TO APPEAL TO REPUBLICANS.
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU?
>> TRANSGENDERISM IS A LOSER.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A LOSER.
67 CORVETTES ARE A WINNER.
I WANT TO --
>> Jesse: HE'S AT 4%.
ADMIT IT.
HE'S AT 4% WITH REPUBLICANS.
HOW IS HE PICKING OFF REPUBLICAN
VOTERS?
HE CAN'T EVEN TURN OUT
DEMOCRATS.
>> IF THE GENERIC BALLOT'S HAS
THE GOP AT 45.6 AND THE
DEMOCRATS AT 40%, THAT'S A
TOSS-UP.
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
BALLOT, GERALDO.
IT'S GOING TO BE A WAVE ELECTION
AND YOU'LL LOSE THE SENATE.
I BET YOU $1,000 RIGHT NOW.
BOTH CHAMBERS.
>> BOTH CHAMBERS?
YOU GOT IT.
>> Jesse: LOOK AT THIS.
>> A MEETING OF THE MINDS.
THERE'S NOW A CONTRACT BETWEEN
THE TWO OF THEM.
LET THE BEST MAN WIN.
>> Jesse: ANYBODY ELSE WANT IN
ON THIS?
>> Dana: I'M GOING T